good morning Millennials good morning
Rachel Lindsay thank you for being here
we're so sorry we're late New York we
have such a great show for you today
because rachel is here at the perfect
time because last night's bachelor
finale yes was unnecessarily long and
boring and treacherous but you're the
perfect person to break it down with
because you'll be able to tell us like
what was actually going on yeah no
absolutely I think three hours they have
to change they need to change some
things in general agree but three hours
they need to start with that like they
have no respect for people's time then
bachelor in paradise is like four hours
per week and the least paradise is like
lively yeah but last night was just not
cool you guys yeah and I was saying on
my Instagram last night because I used
to be obsessed with this show like truly
I couldn't even watch with my friends
cuz they would talk and I would get
angry like I would every word I would
need to hear everything in order to like
really believe in the magic and now I
can't watch three minutes straight
without just fast-forwarding to the next
commercial break just because I'm
getting the gist and I'm moving forward
you know what they're going to say
that's right it's like now you can
complete their sentences you're not
hanging on the words you're giving them
the words right because you know there
are only so many words that they can use
but it always is impressive when someone
like me uses a new word or like a new
phrase and you're like and then everyone
else uses it you know yeah
it catches like wildfire
but anyways we're so happy that you're
here per usual we're gonna hit you with
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast we have a new
sound and lucky for us story number one
is the Bachelorette finale so thank you
start where do we start okay first of
all the winner Oh Garrett
spoiler alert Garrett won um I saw a
spoiler like a while ago but not before
I completed my bracket which I won oh
you picked Garrett I did pick Gary at
first impression because that's what you
said I listened to you you said that you
should look out for the first impression
guy when you went and gave Becca some
advice right the other ladies and I was
like I'm going first impression all the
way what do you think about this trend
of like the past four winners being
first impressions well ok funny thing is
I didn't realize it was a trend because
I didn't watch Jo Jo season or Kaitlyn
season so going into picking Brian and
giving him my first depression rose and
then
him being the winner that just was
natural to me and then I learned oh I
was the first one to do it oh cool and I
realized there was a trend and then with
Becca we started talking about it even
more and I thought I hope she really
picked him to pick him and not like I
hope the deciding factor wasn't first
impression first impression it's worked
for 300 girls surely it'll work for me
but I think they're they're happy and
congrats to Becca yeah say that
congratulations to Becca she looks
really really happy beyond happy yeah
like it was the most it was the most I
think it's like she didn't even care
what she was saying like she was only
looking at Garret like she was giving us
her back she was giving Chris Harrison
her back she did not give a damn which
is nice like she should be so happy her
spray tan was like a little OD it was a
little much but she's beautiful and you
know she had her back and she never let
go of Garrett's arm did you notice no I
did she had a strong grip on his arm the
height I'm like I'll never let go I'll
never let go
but I was you can tell genuinely that
she was just thrilled you know like
that's not how she was at her proposal
with Arie no it's at like the best
feeling that moment wearing you come out
with your man for the first time a
hundred percent the best feeling I mean
you've been trapped in a closet let's
say it for months and now you get to
share your joy with the world and it's
the most exciting feeling but it's also
very scary and then you step into the
real world because you've been protected
this whole time and then you hear all
the negative things people have to say
about your relationship and the choice
that you made so I feel sorry for them
because they're gonna face that this
morning right and like it seems like
everyone who's faced that like re faced
it majorly you even think people were
like so hung up on Peter yeah so there's
no there's no escaping it but it's not
that's why as long as you're happy
that's really all that matters yeah
you've got to focus on it you've got to
cut out like you have to do this day of
media right and everybody's going to be
talking about did she make the right
decision should she have chosen Blake
you think I'm a slave of my favorite you
know from the beginning from the
beginning their connection like came
through your TV
mm-hmm I that's just how I felt and when
she amused lines like our hearts
connected
I'm like I know my heart connected with
you guys too that's about that's really
cute I like felt like she had equally
strong connection like she could have
chose either of them and I would have
felt good about the choice but honestly
from the beginning my favorite was
Colton even though I know he's trouble I
know I like I am NOT a big cult but when
he first came on the show like before we
knew some of the backstory I was just
all in on him and I was like he asked me
The Bachelor so our little sister can go
on and my brother-in-law and I can look
at him every day no I don't think that's
gonna happen like any part of it I don't
need it to happen now I don't think he's
going on paradise and like the Tia drama
who do you thinks gonna be the next
Bachelor I okay I wanted it to be Blake
now that we know I mean I knew she
picked Garrett but right now that we
know it's Blake or he didn't win I want
Blake or wanted Blake but after seeing
Jason do they made such a good case for
him at the men tell all I think it
should be Jason I have to finish I
couldn't finish them Intel all because
everyone was being unbelievably thirsty
and I was like I am NOT giving in to
this so I turned it off but everyone's
obsessed with Jason so now I should
watch it just in case oh I can get on
everyone's level you'll get it like they
made the perfect case for him now I'm
not like that interested in seeing
either one of them like I'm waiting for
more like I need to see more of like
their personality like they're good
Blake and Jason good class acts but like
I was gonna be a good lead I don't know
I like like I feel like he has like
gravitas and a lot of emotion not worth
that people are going to catch on - yeah
I'm looking for women Ravi Thomas
with gravity no I feel like he has like
the emotional capacity to manage 25
women hi I'm a little nervous that he'll
be zeroed it because he seems to be a
guy who's like zeroed in locked in on
one person and you really have to be
able to navigate multiple relationships
when you're the lead yeah I think Jason
might do that better I don't know touch
vampire vibes like it's with his like
back hair but I thought all his
personality was in his hair yes but like
I don't know what I don't think I'd like
what that says
you know but but there is like the
bachelor glow up so maybe someone will
like I don't know
I got a bachelor Becca got such a
everyone does and it's it's really
incredible work that they do know yeah
they do you're the lead you're like
you're this America and you're like the
most watch woman on television for three
months straight yeah yeah it's pasta
those are some big shoes to fill they
are I have some logistical questions for
you because Abeka got a lot of flack
about her wardrobe choices this season
and I'm hearing a lot from me black came
from this seat yeah I could clear that
up
does she make her choices yes okay so
this a lot of people think the stylist
shouts of carry seven who I adore who
does an amazing job I like so I knew it
wasn't Kerry spy I adore him a lot of
people think that he picks out what you
wear but what it is is you walk into
this room like a week before and you
have racks and racks of clothing you
pick what gowns you want to wear you
pick each outfit for the dates you put
it together yourself the clothes he just
puts all the clothes together and then
it's your choice so that that's Becka so
if you were disappointed with certain
things with the sequins the blue one I
was but she's like so beautiful and so
like [ __ ] Gorge she could really wear
anything like her in that dress that
white dress that I wouldn't have chose
but like still she looked amazing last
night with her like shooting till arm
just like she looked fantastic she
really did okay I have another question
for you
your proposal was in a very Windy City
yes would you but her proposal was in a
very hot place yeah Blake was sweat
crying yeah would you rather have had
sweaty proposal or windy proposal I
would have rather had sweaty proposal
really like it was the wind was so bad
my weave was blowing everywhere it was
not attractive if you look closely you
can see tracks it was not cute we
couldn't hear each other I mean I was so
distracted by the elements that I felt
like I couldn't really focus I mean I
was focused but I was also upset I mean
I cry
a lot of people don't know this I cried
right before Brian came to propose to me
because I felt so ugly
due to that wind oh yeah so I would have
rather been a hot sweaty mess but at
least like there wouldn't have been all
this distraction around us and didn't I
think when you were on the show the last
time you had said that they moved the
proposal date up because the wind was
supposed to be so bad the next day no
but then the next day was beautiful in
here day was windy yeah yeah I mean at
least you know the ring didn't fly away
Brian so last night's episode of after
the final Rose was a little bit
different than yours because we were at
your side way we have a photo I just I
can't believe I forgot that we were
there and then last night I forget I was
watching I was like oh my gosh we were
there watching Rachel Lindsay and you
sass her the whole time you watch the
whole episode out on that stage yeah
what was the cause for that form of
torture i torture is the absolute
correct word I mean I was suffering up
there and I think that there's a reason
you didn't see Becca up there this year
I think that they realized that was the
wrong thing to do I mean three hours
watching it live for the first time like
in front of a live audience that was
brutal so it's like I'm reliving all
these emotions and these feelings you
know like frustration happiness whatever
in front of a live audience with
everyone else when normally the lead
gets to watch that days before and deal
with it behind closed doors and be fully
prepared when they walk out on stage aka
Becca
Garrett Blake so Becca had watched that
before last night you believe yeah 100%
100% yeah just like I watched hers the
finale and I was so happy for Rebecca
and then I got completely pissed off at
the same time because she didn't go
through what I went through on that
stage yeah no I totally and that's not
Becca's fault but it's just kind of like
why what was the point of me doing that
and if you remember when I was sitting
there on stage I was like Chris Harrison
was like we're doing a live show you're
gonna break there's gonna be out here
the whole time and I literally looked at
him and I go I don't know why y'all keep
doing stuff like this to me okay I
wasn't happy I'm still not happy and you
had to watch the Peter stuff like
whiskey
yeah that's so that's so crazy I didn't
realize like how stark difference that
was from like this this seemed like easy
breezy your standard final rose that
sucks
yeah well just as her facial for sure
but I'm happy that they realized it was
not right and they corrected it with
Becca yeah that's true yeah she didn't
need to sit out there for three hours
and go through that but either but at
the same time she had a pleasant
conversation with Blake I mean he didn't
tell her she was living a mediocre life
or she was going to so have to deal with
some of the things he was very
supportive of her really supportive I
think he handled like the whole thing
like a total gentleman bachelor in the
making yeah but do you think he's still
in love with her cuz like he was not
over it yeah I think it was very I'm so
glad she brought that up I thought it
was so obvious that he was still into
her he seemed to be struggling on stage
like a lot of times you hear someone say
oh I was crying backstage or oh you know
like I'm having a really hard time like
that happened on my finale but you
didn't see it the way that you saw it
with Blake yeah like I believed
everything Blake was going through know
me too and when you think back to some
of the other like final twos like we've
never had such a like a close race I got
Rayven was here the other week and so
she was final tea with Vanessa and she
was saying like she actually she said
that she thought it was her but that she
didn't like feel like it was right and
so I didn't feel like when she was on
the stage talking to Nick like then any
sort of no she's over it she's over it
like I'm you know she's ever under it
like you know but here like they were
both under it and I don't think they're
either of them are over it and I thought
back it was like so nice to him but how
do you just let go of all those feelings
for someone Beca seems to be over it
yeah now that was it was so I think
that's what made it even harder with
Blake he looked like he was still
struggling and she was over it you could
tell she's moved on and she was totally
happy with Garrett and I just kind of
fell bathroom which brings me to I don't
think he's ready to be the next Bachelor
Blake Blake because he's too in love
with Becca I guess I don't think he's
over it he's a guy who fills all of it
and I just don't think in three months
he's over it well I feel
that used to be the case that's why they
always went with like number three
because that person they could justify
like oh yeah they're ready for love it
wasn't this person but I believe this
person yeah
but then with Becca like she got engaged
and then broken up with and two months
later she was the Bachelorette so like
they I think they're like they're able
to justify people not being over it yet
I mean the fact that they were still
talking about Arie into the season
finale was really unacceptable
um I personally didn't think that Becca
was ready to be the lead I thought like
to be engaged and to go through all of
that and think you're spending your
entire life and then I'm I'm off later
now you're prepared to do that again
possibly with twenty I don't know how
many people came to see her I didn't
think that showed up however you want to
phrase it I just didn't think that she
would be over it either but I mean she
seemed to be and maybe because she was
done
so Terry did it easy yeah you see re
posted on Instagram that him and Lauren
went down to wherever they were them all
do you know they went to the Maldives
I'm so glad they didn't show us that
that conversation let Becca free free
are either go but it sounded like Becca
and the producers wanted him to come
down for some sort of like psycho
conversation ari said Becca and The
Bachelor source Ari said you're not you
don't like Ari I don't think no no I
like actually genuinely liked Ari I
think he's a great person I don't
believe that Becca wanted him to come
down there for a conversation for what
she's got two amazing guys down there in
the finale why are you gonna come ruin
her Maldives trip Ari wanted a trip to
the ball Dave's I would have said yes to
that is crazy well I'm glad they didn't
show it either cuz like I'm done talking
about Ari and like Ari and Lauren seems
so happy they do they have a wedding
date and like they seem perfect for each
other and I always I always saw their
connection and everything he didn't make
sense to me like it was horrible and I'm
just really sad and unfortunate but like
I understood how he could choose back
because his head was telling him like
this woman like she will be an amazing
partner wife etc and like his heart was
saying Lauren but he couldn't justify
that because like she couldn't speak
during the season know
I think that Lauren is perfect for him I
think they're absolutely happy and I
think they're super cute together I just
don't agree with how he did it like at
that age you should have enough
wherewithal to realize like separate
your head from your heart and know what
you want and go after it so I don't
agree with how he did it okay
well everyone it worked out for everyone
except for Blake the TVD on him
people already hating on Becca which is
just so crazy because like the support
member people were been mowing her for
drinks after she got done by Ari and now
they're taking back their venez yeah
I'll send you some memos because I just
want my bachelor bracket I think it's a
hundred bucks so dinner drinks tonight
one drink okay we have so many more
questions for you we'll get to them
after we hit you with the rest of the
stories that you need to know this
morning because even though the bachelor
finale I would last night the world
doesn't stop turning no it's not and
there's some really exciting news for me
personally I'm not sure if you're a lady
Gaga fan but she just announced her Las
Vegas residency
I'm so excited monster I'm a little
monster me too I'm in love with her
everything she does Joanne I'm obsessed
with I know it wasn't like critically
well-received but it was really big
my true friend thanks I true that yes it
was a rebirth I'm so excited to see what
she doesn't I well I'm excited that
she's having two separate type of shows
really I want to go to both I want to do
the jazz piano show and not just like
the big performance yeah to see it all I
have I saw her actually perform when she
was on tour with Tony Bennett and then I
also saw the Joann tour and the Tony
Bennett one was like a little was just
uh less lit I was Joann was like at Citi
Field in the rain it was so crazy she
actually got sick from that concert and
then couldn't go to Canada sorry guys
Wow she's a real fan no but I'm so
excited about this I need to go to Las
Vegas just in general and I need to see
her now and I need to see Celine Dion
have you ever seen her life i okay I was
at the Billboard Awards last year and
she sang and I don't know if I was more
excited for the flute for the Titanic
it's a flute right the Titanic song when
she performed I saw her perform die or I
was for Celine I mean she's a goddess
I I can't even
imagine seeing her whole show but I saw
one song and I was hooked I'm so I
literally am always saying I need to go
to Las Vegas just as I would say to a
same day in and out trip no hotel where
I'm like just as he Selene but now we
can make it like a weekend because Lady
Gaga is gonna be there that's it's like
well overdue right I'm so excited for
her I miss her and I feel like she'll do
like well in Vegas you know I think it's
kind of fun to live there so much event
like you can have such a nice house you
go to the city come back if you think
it's a nice existence for bits for a bit
but anyway she's starting her exclusive
residency at Park Theatre at the new
park MGM Resort on December 28 people
confirms exclusively quote I can't wait
to share in digna with all of my fans
and with Las Vegas we're creating a show
unlike anything I've done before it will
be a celebration of all that is unique
and different within us the challenges
of bravery can be overcome with
creativity and courage that has grown
out of adversity love and music Gaga
tells people in the statement I'm so
hear of it so fans will have their pick
between two different shows Lady Gaga
enigma and Lady Gaga jazz and piano that
is so cool
ci she's a real artist so that's why I
want to see both shows yes I want to see
the different versions of Lady Gaga like
as long as she's not jumping off of a
building like a screeching screeching
cat screeching cat screeching cat like
she did in the Super Bowl I'm good yes
so funny my friends if like if all your
friends jumped off a bridge with you me
oh my god uh her Super Bowl performance
was everything that was and was a
mixture of jazz in piano and like
theatrics cuz people didn't like it I
people are people are you can't please
them I love she crushed it was my
favorite one yet Bruno Mars was great i
katy perry's because that was when i was
obsessed with her no no no Katie didn't
quite do it for me okay I
she did it for me then but Lady Gaga I
think is my favorite one of all time
this past year did not do it for me
Justin Timberlake oh I literally was
like who was it like you know how I feel
about it
yeah no he doesn't she just doesn't do
it for me in general but then the
performance know things and like no
NSYNC
that's not that was the problem I mean I
miss the old Justin you know yeah yeah
we all did it could have just been in
sync and I would have been through that
would have been so cool like and
different but now he just I don't know
mmm Zach my fiance like is obsessed with
him and we had pretty much have the same
taste in music and it's like the one
thing that we really like don't agree on
and he every time I say it like he gets
too upset about the Super Bowl about
Justin Timberlake mean like a mediocre
talentless hack I don't think that I've
got into him the same way that I used to
be I feel like he's super dad vibes now
super dad super dad but I still think
he's insanely talented and I'm still a
fan but not for the Super Bowl please
Gavin who do you think it's gonna be
this year that's a really good question
I love trying to think of who it's gonna
be
I haven't thought about do you think
they'll go old school because we had
Justin mm-hmm before that was Gaga gaga
then you had Beyonce Bruno Coldplay that
didn't need to be a part of it no no
that's weird
that's a weird man it was a no no and it
will never happen again they shouldn't
mix it up like that let's stick to one
genre I agree that was crazy and then
before that I guess was Katy Perry and
then I don't even know before that yeah
it stopped there was there have been
some weird ones like the Black Eyed Peas
see it I'm a black eyed peas fan but I
remember watching that it was like it
didn't register no but they should
definitely have birdie sing the national
anthem
she needs to be redeemed
she really but maybe she should start on
the Super Bowl level she just started
the bottom like a minor league baseball
games and work her way back up to the
majors do you understand where I'm going
it's pretty fair I feel like pit bull
could do the Super Bowl that would be so
much fun think about it
pit bull may be a little flow rider I'm
not even a huge fan but I think it would
be a good show maybe a little JLo shape
there it is I've been saying there is
that it's gonna be pitbull and JLo I
don't know I just pulled it on my ass
they're waiting to like
beep in the key well the Super Bowl is
in Atlanta so we could do like a little
Jon & the east side Boyz Oh like a
throwback Atlanta maybe Outkast be that
would be too much for the Superbowl but
it's like I don't think it's too like
Atlanta yeah well they did the home into
Minnesota with premise love that you can
access I can't say it without it I do my
favorite part about Becca is that she's
from Minnesota and she says bag that's
Garrett pointed that out for us last
night what he fell in love with the way
that she says bag big did he say that
that I must have fast forwarded that but
he said I was listening to her on after
the final rose and I was like about her
accent like really is so crazy and I'm
sure she's it's she's diluting it like
I'm sure she had like some classes but I
just love I love a good accent like that
I never get to hear yeah you know
because people always making fun of my
accent do you really have max we were
very like New York talkers
yes a little bit very accentuated I
really have the southern I really do it
but not really well Zach is also from
Dallas and he doesn't have a southern
accent it's disappointing honestly
except he always says y'all may be off
but I think y'all is like a
grammatically like necessary term I hate
the term you guys think I hate you guys
putting you guys in text it could it's
just y'all is how much are you all you
all be yeah that's like so teacher Lee
you all are in some trouble okay next up
this next story is so crazy and I don't
know why people are so shocked by it but
Mighty Ducks actor Sean Weiss was
arrested after behaving erratically
while high on drugs this the headline
isn't like the most crazy part it's the
photo yeah it's the photo which we have
for you of the actor then and now and he
just he does not look the same also I'm
pretty sure this is the actor from
heavyweights which is okay because to my
heart because we went to a fat camp and
it is not a fully accurate portrayal but
like it gets a couple things right that
was a classic that movie is a classic
Ben Stiller
I can't I actually loved the movie heavy
weight so but what's crazy is like he's
Uncle Tony in the in the movie and like
our camp directors name is tow
like I think it was loosely based off of
our camp because we are like the number
one pack camp in the country yeah
anyways Mighty Ducks co-star Shawn Weiss
was arrested early Saturday in Northern
California California after police found
him allegedly high on drugs and acting
bizarrely with a flashlight people
confirms y 38 was booked after
patrolling officers found him about
12:47 a.m. outside a closed business
complex along the main boulevard in
Oroville with approximately three other
individuals according to lieutenant
Chris Nicodemus the group was behaving
erratically with flashlights such as
Weiss shining a light in his own face
and the officer suspected they might be
under the influence of alcohol or drugs
yeah judging by this picture he's
definitely under the influence of
something and it's just really sad
because you this is he's like one of
these people you like will always
remember as a kid and just to see that
he's like a 40 year old man he's with it
like you're right it's the picture
that's so shocking I know big picture of
him as a child no they said he was 38 I
thought they had the numbers switched
when I saw the picture 83 is what this
is not funny no they're like how old is
he now and they were like 30 and they're
like that's not a 1383 that's what I
thought I was like oh the numbers were
switched before I knew who it was
I mean it's so sad drugs are a terrible
thing like this literally this should be
like a poster of like what drugs can do
to you yeah like it's so sad it's so sad
it's definitely the end of like a an
error or like the dispelling of a myth
of who this person was which is just a
mightyduck
a movie that never did it for me
personally okay can we switch topics
because I understand oh my the Flying V
I do it for you I just I didn't relate
to end it any of the people like the
characters that movie and the Sandlot
like our two classics that I just the
see I don't I'll give you maybe I was
the throwing up scene I don't know I
just the Sandlot I'll give you I cannot
give you Mighty Duck okay for goodness
sakes there was a sequel
I'm saying for me personally like and
the sandlot like those kids were filthy
and it's like I like watching movies
like clueless Legally Blonde like
glamorous and like why am i watching a
bunch of dirty kids right with a big dog
and I know and we were so scared of dogs
growing up so like that did nothing for
us like we're like up Theory confirmed
well I just didn't get it it wasn't
funny but Mighty Ducks my gosh maybe as
an adult I would I would like like it
more Oh try again I will and then bring
me on to talk about it and we'll do a
review and then and I'm not arguing with
you I'm just saying like my personal
experience it's never like different I
get it
next story is really exciting I just
love some branding news like I don't
know how to describe it but there's a
new Colonel Sanders at KFC and it's
Jason Alexander I love George Costanza
I love KFC and they're like Colonel bit
and it was Reba McEntire before which
was like [ __ ] everything amazing and
I love how they like they were so
low-key about like however the Colonel
Sanders kept changing and it was like
always someone that we knew and now it's
like a thing and I think it's really
cool is well I know Reba cuz I thought
that was great but who else was it it
was Rob Lowe it was yes those
commercials must have been short-lived
I don't know Rob Lowe yeah and then also
that guy was it ever like Chevy Chase
like that guy from Oh Christmas vacation
movies yeah I think so I don't know or
maybe I'm just like Chevy Chase I don't
know I don't remember
a Chevy before our time I know for sure
they were the only one I like love is
Caddyshack yeah I've never even seen
that am I gonna you had really likes a
Chevy or Chevy
I think Chevy Chevy Chevy like the car
that's what I said but anyways Jason
Alexander some new Colonel Sanders and I
just like one I feel like this is like a
great paying job like making that KFC
money yeah and to mistake your faces all
over the television and it's a fun gig
ya know I miss him I hope that he
channels George Costanza somehow in that
KFC
Sanders role I feel like he will good
good
I don't know I mean electing big things
yeah I'm expecting big things and it's
just so weird how like then it's just a
commercial on TV like nothing ever
happens it's not like a movie that comes
out it's just a commercial but it could
that would be cool
or like how they did the casting of
JonBenet on that looks like the casting
of Colonel Sanders did oh they did yeah
that's it was like supposed to a movie
about her murder and then it became a
movie about casting the girl to play her
in a movie about her murder I didn't
finish it I just want to know who killed
Romany who do you think a family member
for sure yeah I just don't know who I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna point any
fingers yeah her knee
you're the prosecutor I just think that
it was someone in the family like either
someone in the family or a super close
family friend it was not just some
random stranger fair convinced and do
you think Amanda Knox did it I wasn't
ready for that question yeah once I go
down this path I have like a few things
and just like Casey Anthony
it's almost how I feel about OJ maybe
she didn't do it but she knows who did
okay I was indeed I just had I got no
answers I don't like that yeah no oh my
gosh no I don't like that he's like I
wasn't invested in the story to begin
with so now I'm invested you got me
invested and you owe me no answers she
knows something yeah let's put it like
that
okay that's all about okay you know
something and that's your that's the law
talking yeah okay next up our fifth and
final story is really crazy and random
but according to cheddar TV apparently
way more people are going into plastic
surgery surgeons offices and asking to
like look like snapchat filters like
soap or thinner noses bigger eyes bigger
lips and honestly I could I could see
how that could happen
like I don't I want to get plastic
surgery I wouldn't show a picture of
someone else I would show like the best
picture of me which is like filtered
heart version on snapchat no I okay I
heard this story before and it baffles
my mind like why would you want to look
like a Bratz doll right like the big
eyes
no I don't know like this is so
unnatural it's the trend in a selfie
it's the trend on Instagram but I don't
want to see real life filters walking
around here like I don't want to see
that on people's heads
I guess you see someone like you see all
these people on Instagram even with
filters or without filters like there's
facetune and people don't look how they
look on Instagram not at all but I just
want to like see one of those people in
person and just be like confirmed that's
like not humanly possible okay cool
it's not humanly possible I think it's
weird and I think it's sad I think it
says a lot about us we're walking into
offices saying I want to look like a
filter I don't want to look real reality
like I'm all for plastic surgery that's
great if you want to alter something
change freshen up a little bit but the
fact that you want to look like a fake
person ID like or an animated thing I
don't know I'm just like not into it I
think it's sad it is sad and and the
fact that you think you can look like
that they can't make you look like a
filter no they can't like they can't
like thin like they can do you're the
bridge of your nose but they can't like
make the width
scowler or like the skin a certain way
like I mean it's a yeah it's like an
overlay okay unless you're gonna walk
around with a screen on your face that's
so interesting because I like to me the
story made sense then now it's like
these are like I've changed her mind
you really guess that's what lawyers do
you're a great lawyer how's the law
treating you the law is great a lot of
people don't think I still work I
totally do but I work part time I think
people fail to realize that oh do you
what cuz you do so much because you also
are doing correspondent work for ESPN
which is amazing so excited about dream
job I'm sure yeah and then you're also
like influencing you were in the Bermuda
with Rabab which I want to ask about so
what was that is that was that like as
fine and cool and beautiful as it looked
it was even better than I thought really
like I always have been like what's
revolved what's revolve and then I
started researching it and then I
started shopping it and then I got to
become a part of it and it was so the
people are fantastic the places are
great it's just such a good time and I
can't talk about it enough it's one of
those things where you just have to
experience it I did not know what I was
getting myself into but boy am I glad I
got into it
like so many times people think like
Instagram stuff is like so fake and
everyone's just taking pictures and not
having fun which i think is a case the
case a lot of the time but like revolve
does a really good job of like having
good in person experiences that I don't
translate really well to social media
keyword it's an experience like that's
been your base with all your girls yeah
like I was there Rayven Whitney Amanda
Stanton I think that was it from
bachelor world but that was enough like
we it's an honor it's an honor to be
invited I'm sure I feel that way now
bring me back and Ermita was have you
been to Bermuda before no it looks
insane and there really are pink sands
it's gorgeous and I feel like a lot of
people don't realize how close it is
it's two hours from New York right I
think they just started doing like
direct flights because I've heard of
people like going on their honeymoons
there it's just so funny how like trendy
vacation spots like pop up it's like
this place always existed well you have
to go okay well two-hour flight and
direct flight I'm in that I can do and
the MIT the triangle myth it's over with
I'm Lee Earhart I thought about it what
would Amelia Earhart think about
revolving Bermuda you guys she's fine
her plane maybe she's there a lot of the
conspiracy theories that's a whole other
thing
I wasn't yeah I don't even know enough
oh I don't know she was such a big part
of my childhood I feel like what sure I
just feel like I studied her so much
like just we were always talking about
her she was like such a know an iconic
figure and now it's just like Zak you
should be her for Halloween that would
be like our ads well housewife reference
have you been watching Real Housewives
of New York yes
team Carolyn T Bethenny oh this is a
tough one I was a neither can i do that
choice yes he's how I guess he was
explaining I was definitely team Carol
but then I feel like Carol's being a
little nasty and I think you know what
bothers me about this whole thing I'm a
backup
Andy I feel like you're not giving us
the full story I don't understand why we
don't understand why they don't get
along there has to be some reason and we
it's is it like because Adam wanted to
be paid on this Puerto Rico trip is it
because carols with tensley is it
because Bethenny is just a difficult
friend I
No I need answers I'm neither I feel
like they feel the same way like they
don't know what it is either it's like
all these little like micro aggressions
that like led them to this point I'm
just feeling like contentious toward
each other and now they can't they can't
get back from it I think okay this is
while slightly blame Carol I think that
carol has been feeling this way but she
never expressed it until it just like
boiled over right and then she found
Tinsley and she has this friendship with
her and now she's just like Beth and
he's like I don't get it you never said
anything and I think because Carol was
feeling this way but she just never said
anything and so I think that poor
Bethany you know like maybe if carol had
been honest in the beginning mm-hmm it
would be easy I really think that's what
it is Carol's been feeling this way yeah
I think like Cal was just done being the
sidekick because she got her own
sidekick and it's like that was just how
their relationship works and now you're
changing the dynamics of their agent
ship which changes their relationship
yeah overall yeah and you can't have
like two queen bees yeah I felt bad
Bethenny is like reaching for a friend
and it's like does she have any I think
she must have friends off the show but I
feel like um I don't know but I feel
like she deserves friend like she
deserves I feel like she had such a hard
time like finding people like her tribe
you know yeah Bethenny's a tough cookie
yeah hard I just if she softened up a
little bit I think that people would be
more receptive to her but I understand
her because I can be hard like that and
a tough cookie but she needs to soften
it up a bit yeah I'm sure it's just like
hard right but you can't you also can't
have it all like she's so successful
like if she also had amazing friendships
and amazing relationships like that that
can't you can't have it all that's just
not how a point the cards are dealt yeah
okay we have so many questions for you
ooh and one thing that here are the
morning toasts we've been trying to get
to the bottom of and I couldn't leave
done a pretty good job hope I can help
is what happened at your birthday party
okay
how can I describe this first of all I
am on good terms with all my friends
right let's just preface it with there
might have been a bit of drinking we
might have had a good time so maybe I
was I can be Anna Mae
and dramatic so maybe I was a little bit
but basically my dear sweet bachelor
friends showed up super late to the
party and then and they mind you they
came in town for my party and then there
was an uninvited guest who also popped
up so didn't come into the party because
it was section often he wasn't allowed
but bought a table right next outside of
my party and they all went over to that
table so I'm mad
a little toxicated too and then they all
leave with him to go to another place
left my party yes so it was my party and
I did cry so I was I was very offended
that it was my birthday party they left
with this person I do not care for and
partied with him and then left and went
with him so I thought kind of like wow
are these my friends no yeah that's
[ __ ] up we've got some we heard about
this uninvited guest
and then but we're even Alexis for like
kind of a I guess because they were
totally in the wrong it's not cool you
guys but no Craven wasn't I still love
you Alexis me too no you're about a
number one and honestly ho you can only
call out your true friends like that
like you didn't care about these girls
like you wouldn't even care that they
like oh if you you know I called them
out I sent them all like this nasty text
message and then the next day I was like
okay I'm over it I love you guys I mean
like if you're like sisters you know
yeah I was mad I said it we were done
it's whatever
we're we're on great terms and I'll be
so you know supporting them great I'm
glad we cleared that up yeah there was
so much speculation like in the toasters
group like people were trying like piece
together who was there I was like we're
just gonna go straight to the source you
guys yeah I was mad at them I mean yeah
I was mad I said it you know I don't
dwell on things like that so I was over
it as quickly as I was on it how do you
feel about all your friends I'm moving
to Dallas is it just like the dream I
love that they're moving to Dallas you
know Ravens already there
Alexis he'll be there next month now I
just need to get Astra their shadows to
Astra who's going on paradise which
starts today
oh my god paradise tests are tonight
that's exciting I can meet I need some
choose day/night programming so this is
perfect yeah I do too yeah two seasons
like the week comes one Bravo below that
I don't like balloon I only watch like
when I'm just really bored and I enjoy
it but I just don't know all the
background information so I can't make
informed decisions yeah I feel like
Astrid is a type who couldn't actually
find love in paradise because I feel
like she's got it going on you know she
knows who she is yeah and like that's
the type of person who will attract love
you know what I mean I'm excited I
totally agree because everyone's like
super close to Astrid right like you
always see her in our pictures we might
celebrate her birthday but you didn't
see her on the show right so people are
like well who is this Ashton and I'm so
excited for her own paradise because
you're gonna get to see how cool she is
and then I feel like pastor wasn't her
place you know she couldn't open up a
paradise she was gonna be so I'm super
excited for her that's so exciting
also something that's so interesting is
Adam was from your season and it seemed
like you guys had a great friendship
like and that he made it really far even
though like we never really saw your
guys's dates or anything but just
because you were friends so like when
you were when he was on your season like
were you setting him up in your head
with like maybe one of your other girls
like do you ever think that you ever
think that human Raven would be the
match well I did
I will not as I was going through the
season you know there's certain people
that it's like you know who your top are
you know there's people like I could
date outside of this and we get along
really well we just need more time and
then there's people that are big-time no
no's right so I knew Adam was a super
cool guy thought he was great he just
wasn't for me after the show when I
found out he was going on paradise I
thought I told Raven that she would be
really good for Adam and I also told
Astra that I was like if either one of
y'all go to paradise I think you both
would get along really well with Adam
and then Astrid was in a relationship
last year yeah that makes sense with
that demon
[Laughter]
it seems really cute on social media and
then it was over
yeah I'm not a fan I understand so I'm
sure you get this question all the time
and I so do i and I hate it but um
wedding plans well okay let's just be
honest would I like a t.v wedding sure
that means I don't have to like pay for
anything that means I don't have to plan
it you know and I don't have no desire
to like plan all the minor details of a
wedding I just don't but it's not up to
me and there are a lot of moving parts
so people are like when are you getting
married I don't know because if it's if
it's on TV that's kind of that up to me
but I also don't want to be held or
trapped to is my wedding going to be on
TV or not right so I kind of have a
timeline in my head by the summer I want
to be married you know ideally I'd like
it to be the spring but well originally
I wanted December it's August that's not
quite I've only started doing the dress
have you started yeah no I have I'm
gonna work with Randy ROM in New York oh
my god that's so excited no I went and
looked at dresses yesterday and it's the
second time I've done and done it and so
I've originally talked about this idea
of what I wanted like with a pantsuit
oh wow and I'm like completely opposite
now after looking at dresses so I hope
people are going to be really surprised
because I feel like I want my dress to
show the side of me that people don't
get to see that Bryan gets to see but
most people don't that's so exciting
ya know I'm really excited about the
dress but anyways yes back to your
original question though wedding ideally
by next summer
I mean he or not TV or not I just don't
want to keep waiting I'll be 34 by next
summer
yeah it's but you feel like ready to get
married because some master couples like
need like more time to be engaged and
get to know each other but you guys are
there we've been engaged for 15 months
that's crazy yeah so I'm like ready at
this point okay we know we get it are
any of your bachelor friends gonna be
bridesmaids cuz no all right well
because I just I have so many friends
they'll definitely be there they'll have
a whole row dedicated to them right but
I'll probably have my sisters Jess your
sister and sister that's that's so smart
you don't hurt anyone
it's a cop-out yeah also one of my
favorite things when you were the
bachelor at you were hanging out with
Kris Jenner yes you guys keep in touch
well I know Christian I know Cory I'm
not Cory for like 15 years I know it's
such a silly sad how you were hanging
out with and not even from bachelor
stuff no not from bachelor stuff because
I know Cory and like I've known Cory
Cory went to college with my sister
so I used to go and visit all the time
so they were friends I became friends
I'm friends with a lot of my sisters
friends and so that's really how it all
happened and then she's such a bachelor
Bachelorette and he was like you'd have
to come and meet Chris so that's why you
just have to I just yeah I just happen
to know Christian there's boyfriend
that's how was the home how are the
snacks okay first of all when I walked
in when I came and I came through the
back so I didn't know I was at the house
do you know when I knew I was at the
house when I saw the checkered floor
yeah and I thought oh my god yeah I
didn't freak out she wasn't there yet
okay so like her assistant was there
some I guess you wouldn't recognize the
house cuz it's not the house on TV so
you wouldn't even know which house huh
no the house that they film is like the
Jenner house is just like some show
house because they don't show their real
house but the checkered floor yeah the
inside is okay okay okay so if you got
to the outside you waiting no because
the outside looks nothing like what you
thought so I was like I didn't realize
that and so I was like oh my gosh
there's the checkered floor then I
walked down the hallway with all the
black black-and-white photos and I
thought I'm here you guys I'm here it's
but she wasn't there and then she when
she came in super nice like made me a
play cleaned off my place she is even
more beautiful in person
North was there she was not receptive to
me she's not I tried to do this and yeah
we just talks we just a had really good
conversation it was like I had known her
for years I mean she is truly like salt
of the earth really yeah I think he
might be the first person to say that I
would tell you I mean I really was there
for hours it's not like I met her in
passing I was there for hours and just
had a real conversation with her that's
amazing
have you been watching the show did you
watch I don't really watch anymore but I
was any night's episode was explosive
I saw clips and it kind of pulled me in
a bit yeah how dare they talk to
Courtney like that oh we have a demon
over here well I don't know the
backgrounds right but I heard what Kim
said to her and then it's like
regardless of what's going on how can
you talk to a sister like Anna do you
don't see Courtney get emotional and you
could hear her over the phone she was
choked up she talked to Khloe and Kim's
like yelling in the background and I
thought yeah that yeah okay another
question we got for you is how much say
does the Bachelorette have in the ring
style that her man's chooses the
Bachelorette has a hundred percent say
okay and so does whoever the bachelors
choosing the last two girls so what
happens is you the last two whether
you're girls or guys whatever you tell
the lead well okay I'm gonna be getting
confusing let me just talk about the
Bachelorette your last two guys will ask
you what you want your ring to look like
okay and which both of my guys day
that's a question I also get did Peter
ask you that even though he knew he
wasn't going to propose yes he asked me
what I wanted my ring to look like and
so did Brian and so I told them this
this is exactly how I described my ring
so when they sit with no Lane they know
what to look for because you've already
described what you like right but then
what Blake chosen what Garrett chose
were so different did yeah so we give
one of them false information I don't
think so I mean like I can't I can only
speak from my experience and I told both
of them that this was the exact ring I
want it now Peter never picked a ring
because he wasn't afforded that
opportunity but so I don't know how it
would have happened I don't I don't know
if she described two different ones and
either/or I'm not sure pretty only this
the ring that she originally got indeed
Shari with was like so similar to my
ring now
I don't remember what it was oval with a
halo and I'm band and I was like and
then that ring was recycled and given to
Claire and Benoit the noise
yeah it was the same it was the same
ring that's what people don't realize
that I had my eye on that ring I was
like where's that ring and end up I'm
sure was bad yeah I know lame feeling oh
is Neil I've never met no lame that's
crazy well think about it like the guys
were the only ones that go to him and he
shows the ring and then he gets out of
there he doesn't stay for the proposal
he's gone like he knows his role he
knows his place he's out of there very
interesting yeah I've never met him he
seems like a cool dude but like he yeah
he's been through this a few times you
know yeah he's so excited about it
though like you know ever like shook
over Becca's ring that it was gold band
I was jealous actually eventually I
wanted a gold band TV I wanted a stack
of bands actually and they said no you
need to pick out a stone so I actually
loved that hers was gold
I liked it too I like thought about
maybe Rose go but I just I like classic
when it comes to stuff like this you
know not taking too many chances
yeah no no no your rings gorgeous your
ring storages our rings are kind of
similar well thank you so much for
joining us and taking all of our
questions and explaining trust ins and
outs of what might have happened last
night I look forward to bachelor in
paradise tonight you'll be watching
right I'll be watching for sure do you
know like for the most part what who
ends up where they're all your friends
yeah do you think like it'll be a good
season from what you've heard
oh I heard it's going to be crazy really
I mean I think they're well first of all
in the previews there are a lot of
people I have no idea who they are so I
think that that's interesting myself new
people but they seem like a lot of
people went down to Paradise a lot yeah
I think they're going to be a lot of
storylines that's always interesting is
why Paradise is great because there is
so much to work with where it's the
bachelor it's like stretching like a one
thing over three months off and three
hours I was about to say three hours and
I will give you this information
I heard that bathroom paradise was so
good and they had so much content that
they stopped it early like they didn't
even feel like stopped it a few days
early Wow because they had so much good
stuff so look forward to that is a great
teaser to let us go into tonight
we Jonesy thank you so much where can
everyone follow you keep up with you and
the amazing work that you're doing
I you can follow me on at v-- Rach
Lindsey on Twitter and Instagram I have
a website Rachel Lindsey official comm
coming out very soon but you can
subscribe to it right now and yes I
still practice law catch me on hopefully
your local sports whatever you like to
watch and on Access Hollywood I've been
doing that too co-hosting now yeah just
you can check out everything that I'm
doing thank you so much for having me
maybe I'll be back in this chair wait I
have one more question for you because
people were asking why weren't you and
Brian at after the final rose usually
they bring back like the previous
couples where you guys invite in well
one no we weren't invited into I
wouldn't have gone not in that no shade
it's just I don't want to sit for three
hours right like I can watch Becca's
happiness for from afar right yeah okay
thanks for clearing that have a great
day everyone we will see you tomorrow
Claudia will be back it'll be a regular
scheduled programming make sure to watch
little children because we'll be talking
about it tomorrow for toast movie of the
week bye bye
you